okay today i'm making pancakes no my
mouth this is my favorite pancakes
triangle cake
not only is shakira a grammy-winning
international superstar she's also a
whiz in the kitchen
[Music]
okay so maybe not a whiz per se but she
is the sweetest mama ever we try to do
stuff that every family would do the 44
year old mom of two shared a clip to
tick-tock on sunday making pancakes with
her two sons six-year-old sasha and
eight-year-old milan hey guys
[Music]
ready
[Music]
is
[Music]
her song choice the mission impossible
theme song
[Music]
and in the caption shakira called the
whole thing an adventure
[Music]
all right so probably not exactly the
pancakes they were going for but that's
support from her kiddos
too cute of course i want to share with
my fans and i want them to like it it's
not the first time shakira and her fam
have welcomed fans into their lives at
home
last month the colombian superstar
proved to those dancing jeans run in the
family
[Music]
yep that's shakira and her boys busting
a move to jay balvin's hit with skrillex
into ghetto
[Music]
balvin showed off his moves on tick-tock
when the track dropped in july and
shakira and her kiddos seem to be
inspired
needless to say shakira's fans are
loving her content on tick tock which
obviously includes a lot of dancing
[Music]
but my personal fave tell them to send
it to shakira
wait you're shakira
that's shakira do-adding a video by
singer shuba who racked up tons of views
of her own after pretending to be
shakira ordering a pizza
that's okay i said i want a pizza and i
want
[Music]
[Music]
you don't confuse them with mountains
that is a super choice would you like
any signs no no no no no no
no no no no no no
[Music]
you